a lot of parents now working on holiday
shopping for their kids and if you're
struggling with what to get you are not
alone
but we have some simple strategies to
help you out joining us now via zoom of
course is sue groener
a parenting expert entrepreneur and
author sue thanks so much for joining us
we appreciate your time and we're happy
to be doing this for you oh it's good to
speak with you we're going to get right
into it because you have seven rules
essentially for stress free giving can
you
break those down for us sure the first
one is to create some guidelines
um i think it's really important that
when you're
asking your kids for a list that you say
you know the number of gifts they can
have maybe one big one one
a few little ones or maybe you're giving
them a budget
but give some sort of guidelines and
even include
you know if you don't want to get
violent video games tell them no nothing
that's violent
i like that you put guidelines in
because you know if the 16 year old says
hey
i'd like a corvette you need a little
perspective right uh what are some other
what are some other rules that you
really want to impart for our viewers
that are just entering december and
going okay
what can i do to be ready okay if you're
asking for a list
avoid judge judgment so don't say
well why do you have this on your list
i'm not getting you that if you're
asking them for a list then
you know accept what's on there and you
know if you can get it for them
be okay with impracticality if the gifts
are you know something that they don't
really need
isn't that really what a gift is all
about and if they do need a special coat
or a new pair of sneakers
then you know make sure that they're a
little extra special
um let's see what else give without
expectations and this is kind of a hard
one for all of us
usually that means if you give the gift
and it doesn't get used or it's
mistreated or it's thrown on the floor
or it's shared with a friend and they
keep it
it's a gift we can't have expectations
of how
our gift that we're giving is going to
be used um
respect what's on their list also so if
your child is asking for something
that's red
try to get it red and not blue you know
it's really important to them
that they're specifying so really try to
go for that
and you know what consider some
experiential gifts as well
because you know those are also a lot of
fun
and normally i would say if it wasn't
coveted
dirt but now the experiential gifts can
be doing things with you
especially people have a little less
disposable income
how about coupons for you know
30 extra minutes of screen time give
them a pack of 10 of those your kids
will
love that and finally i think it's
important if you can
give some gifts that give back it helps
to teach your kids a little bit about
gratitude and how good it feels to be
giving help them
find a charity that they love usually
little kids love something to do with
with pets or with schools
so there's a lot of there are a lot of
fun things you can do
sue that is great stuff i love the
message with your last point there
on giving tuesday of course i also like
to give without expectations because who
knows the gift you give might get
re-gifted
whatever happens to it right you're
giving without expectations
we wish you a very merry christmas thank
you for joining us on channel 8